[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up i'm wingman and i'm stevo
and we're on this week's episode of
truth or dab
it's actually going down right now pal
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
truth or dab the hot one special where
we give our guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last dab and today i'm excited to
welcome wee man and steve-o two of the
stars of jackass forever we should also
shout out stevo's wild ride podcast keep
an eye out for tour dates coming to a
city near you and on an occasion like
this we've got to shout out stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and then he
teased it on hot ones and now it's
finally here the butthole destroyer
available on amazonstivo.com
also for those in the southern
california area stop by we man's chronic
tacos a delicious lunch pairing for
today's episode if ever there was one we
man stevo welcome to truth or dab always
good to see you brother thanks for the
love too and we man we're gonna start
with you sure so i'm sure that over the
years being on a show like jackass i
suspect you've had all types of
disagreements with industry overlords
what's the single specific worst note or
piece of creative feedback you ever
remember getting from a tv network or
movie studio executive
the worst note words i'm aware of a good
one
oh yeah yeah um on wild boys which was a
show we did for mtv after the first
jackass movie we routinely filmed
something that was outrageously
inappropriate to include in the first
cut of the show so that when it went to
the standards and practices board we
could say oh yeah you know we gave you
that we called them red herrings so when
we were in russia on the final wild boys
trip
me and one other person who shall remain
unnamed were wearing
white i believe polar bear mascot suits
with holes cut out in the nether region
and
uh activities
were filmed the note came back from the
standards and practices board saying
please remove the polar bear
wow and it actually segues rather
poetically to my next question i'm
curious if there is a jackass segment
that's buried in a vault somewhere
because the folks at smp just never
wanted it to see the light of day
i wonder if
we know about the same ones yeah this is
i've got at least three for jackass
that's true
box downstairs
box downstairs oh you don't know about
box downstairs
box owned it was a great idea he just
got in a box and tucked in some pillows
around him taped it up rolled it down a
huge flight of cement stairs and it was
violent as hell there was also when
knoxville shot himself with the 38
caliber smith and wesson handgun oh yeah
and when he said i'm johnny knoxville
and i'm gonna get hit by a car real soon
yeah a car just came flying he went
through the windshield rolled over they
asked him what were you thinking when he
got hit by a car and his answer was
i wore two pairs of jeans so i'd be
this is safe to be a tough game today
open books we man stevo
hey you know what i'm hungry
there is diving in diving in first one
always the showmen i'll try the first
one so this one i had a feeling it was
gonna go this one's
the last dab
it's actually pretty hot
oh yeah
jackass it's long inspired it's fair
share of spin-offs and i know that you
are forever with your guys so this might
be a tough one to answer it might be a
wing but i'd like you to rank these jack
these jack off
you got to bring some jacking off right
now dm screen i'd like you to rate these
jackass derivatives from best to worst
bad grandpa the dudesons nitro circus
wild voice
i'll do
it um yeah that is a little poof
so bad grandpa
the dude sins wild boys and nitro circus
yep
from bad from best to worst oh from best
to worse
wow boy's the best
you
thanks bro yep even though we got paid a
lot more from
uh bad grandpa
all right
we weren't even in it
we'll do
uh bad grandpa next for us
we'll be we'll be selfish on that
and then i'll go tied
nitro circus and the dudesons
for last all right we man here's a
question for you that might also be
tough to answer because i know that
you're a metal head forever in the bands
like slayer black sabbath hardcore punk
bands like the circle jerks i'm curious
of the bands that you grew up listening
to and idolizing which one fell off the
hardest and why oh
remember when we went to go see iron
maiden yeah i've seen iron maiden a
hundred times yeah i mean i'm not saying
that okay no they haven't fallen off
careful around your eyes careful around
your eyes no i know i'm doing it that's
right that's why i ate with this hand
and i'm doing the back of his hand man
i've only done one and i'm kind of dying
i've done one bite and i feel good i ate
the whole thing
you're gnarly
um
from
all the bands
i will say this
someone personally let me down when i
met him and i wasn't even i i knew of
him and he considered a rock guy but i
wasn't a fan
kid rock
[Music]
oh
yeah
he cooked out on me i was like huge kook
all right moving on here to the third
round of uh truth and dab today
stevo jackass it's all about getting the
best footage if you get the footage you
get the most screen time yep is there a
stunt or segment that was done by
someone else that you're just insanely
jealous of that you didn't get to do it
yeah you make a valid point jackass is
largely a battle of attention [ __ ]
for screen time
i have one it came real early on it was
the first movie
uh
manny came up to me and wanted to bite
me in the nipple yeah with the little
mini alligator and i was like oh hell no
and then he went up to knox
did it and it became iconic poster gif
everything in the world and i'm like are
you kidding me that's good yeah i'm like
that did make me wonder of all the
jackass castmates who is the one person
that is most likely to back out of a
stunt at the midnight hour out of pure
panic and alarm for what's about to go
down i think there's two
and those two cast members are uh
chris and lacy
and danger aaron
we all put up a fight but aaron and
preston put up a pretty good fight
the only example i can think of where
somebody really backed out at the last
second was dave england on the riot
squad he was just like i'm too stressed
out i can't do it and then it was just
bam and done
oh
oh that was crazy
well this is just amazing bts off to the
second to last round already which is
amazing
okay i am hungry there we go diving back
in
front of the show questions back
we man from getting into a club to
scoring a quick payday what's the most
shameless way that you've leveraged
jackass's notoriety
um
damn you don't drop your own name to get
speed dialed in any situations
uh
i'm i okay
i will i will say this this is a funny
one i was at a bar drinking irish car
bombs in the little bucket class with
the shot glass in him
and i had three chicks
like fighting like no i'm taking him
home no i'm taking home now and i was
just having fun getting wasted like
and i just started throwing the glasses
behind the bar
order another one
so my buddy starts pulling me out of the
bar
and the owner comes up and goes what are
you doing
and he goes dude he's in five minutes
he'll probably destroy your he's a
liability yeah and he goes don't care
making the most money i've ever made
tonight he can stay and burn the whole
building down and my body is like all
right he's
your problem then there you go
ma'am
i was in that same situation before
jackass and i went to jail
all right well we are on to the last
round and in the last round we have a
very special guest let's make this a hot
sauce let's bring jasper
to that table come on in
straight through jasper just take it hey
what's up guys
we have jasper in the building it is a
hot sauce party easy
jasper dolphin is a very big celebrity
and he's also a new new cast member on
jackass i'm a new guy he's a new guy
it's the star of jackass forever
there's a dab oh my god this is so
terrifying all right to jackass forever
jasper we man stevo to the people
watching
it's going
[Music]
down it doesn't
it just tastes like hot
like
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
wait was the prank on him
the whole time this this whole wave i
have is a prank on me i [ __ ] myself
i'm scared
i'm serious
oh
diving off the deep end
big
carolina reaper got a hollow pepper
basically a mix
of the hottest peppers in the world all
having a party in my mouth right now
dude i took one bite of the first one
i took one bite of the first one that
one was like pretty good i was busting
my eyes started in the water yeah
this one
oh it's happening
ah i swear i never had a wings hot ain't
gonna lie i thought it was like oh
they're just overdoing it's not really
that hot
it's that hot let me ask you a question
jasper you have seen these guys
going through this show today
turning it into truth and dab
is this more or less how you've come to
know them are they more tame are they
less tame on the show today than
observing them on set
honestly oh it is kicking in
it's going in my nose now i have a good
team right it's in my nose dude
i'm eating
[Music]
yeah yeah i didn't hear a word you said
because my mouth is on fire
those on the line are they crazy
and you're filming yeah eating the last
ones to try to save yes 100 up and down
these guys are great we all had a good
time filming a movie
my first movie very happy especially
with these type of people
the naughtiest that we could find these
type of people yeah
little people
jasper was awesome on set dude yep yeah
you asked who would back out of a stun
and the answer is not josh
he was down jasmine was down on a level
that made me uncomfortable whoa
that is the highest of compliments
coming from ceo and speaking of down for
whatever coming in today
truth or dap turning it in to truth and
dab is there anything that you guys want
to say to the people before we roll
credits and get everyone to an ice bath
it's fire dude
it's fire only in theaters
october 22nd
they didn't give me no water or milk
i didn't drink it so that's all for you
back that's some hot milk i threw up
i finished
that was awesome
did you snort him the talk no no oh i
was just playing with the milk the
secret was gonna help but like probably
just look crazy now
he looks like an old man now
your mustache went gray
all right now it's coming out my nose
[Laughter]
oh there we go
good girl
wendy what's going on everybody this is
sean evans and would you take a look at
how we've set the table take a look at
this this is the hot ones oxford pennant
collab a classic american company
buffalo new york in fact shout out to
bill
these right here they're perfect for the
dorm room they're perfect for the hot
ones party that you're throwing at your
place perfect for the sports cave to get
yours visit
shop.firstbeast.com that's
shop.firstbefeast.com to get your hands
on the hot ones oxford pennant
careful around the eyes
[Music]